hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the other match of
the
semi finals of the opera your rapid
westley silver system or jabba
and this is the third game of their
match first game was won by wesley so
then rajabo retaliated with the white
pieces and now we have the third game
where wesley has the white pieces
and it's quite the game uh so let's
check it out there's a
there there's quite a lot to cover so uh
uh
let's start uh we have e4 by wesley uh
and c5 our job goes for the uh for the
sicilian defense we have knight to f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to b5 going
for the
uh dean of rosso limo uh we have g6
and now castles yeah black goes with
bishop to g7 the bishop is now fiance to
knight f6
maybe castles is coming and we have c3
preparing to strike in the center
and now knight to f6 so this is all been
played before
nothing nothing out of the ordinary here
the pawn is under attack so
wesley defends it rook to e1 and here
are a job of castles
and finally d4 striking in the center
uh we have d5 black strikes back and now
as the e4 pawn is attacked twice a
westley advances it's the e5
we have knight to e4 and now uh first
capture sun seasick with bishop captures
b
captures and now bishop to e3 so again
all this has been played before knight b
to d2
is a bit of a more common move but
bishop to e3 also very popular so bishop
to e3
adding another defender to the bishop to
the pawn defend uh
defending on d4 but now as the b dupont
has been left undefended uh
rajab immediately tries to take
advantage of this so c
captures c captur sunday for end queen
to b6 going after
that b2 pawn uh we have queen to c1
defending and
now uh rook the b8 is possible going
after the b2 pawn then white would play
something like b3
uh but uh tamer goes for a5 instead
later on you can play a4
and challenge that b3 pawn so here
knight to c3 and now
knight captures we have queen captures
uh b captures could also be possible but
then you just have a backwards pawn on
c3
you're gonna have uh you're gonna have
problems in the future
uh getting it anywhere and for example
after bishop to f5
it's just uh it's just a great position
uh for black not uh not
want to go into voluntarily so instead
we have queen captures on c3
and now comes bishop to f5 and now this
position has been reached three times in
the database there is a game anigiri
versus like
liam from 2019 it was a blitz game and
anish won that game with
knight to d2 and also uh unknown game is
uh rasmus wanna versus uh gurkish where
h3 was played and again white won this
game it was the
subway sieges in 2019 so basically black
never won this position
but rajab will try so here b3 by wesley
and it is only now as of move 15 that we
have a completely new game and b3 is in
fact
the absolute strongest move recommended
by the engine so wesley
definitely uh prepared for this
variation and rajabo will have to be
very careful
so rook f2b8 and now you can see that
how much pressure rajabo has on that
queen side both of the rooks
the the rook and queen are slicing
through the nb file and look at the
bishop pair slicing the board in half
so sort of like playing some sort of a
weird uh
benoni structure uh only only maybe
better
uh we'll see so here rook after b8 and
now
knights the d2 adding another defender
to the b3 pawn
at some point white wants to play a3 and
he doesn't want his b3 pawn to hang
we have h5 our job of uh refrains from
going a4 right away so first he wants to
expand a little bit on the king side
with
h5 h3 and now again uh
decides against a4 and shifts the rook
to c8 so it's kind of like he changed
his mind he
first had a plan then maybe wanted to
play a4 but now he decided
no let's put this rook here to defend
this one and then we're gonna bring this
rook to b8
and okay we have rook 8 to c1
now also developing this rook and bishop
to f8 now with ideas of e6 maybe the
bishop can come to b4 in the future
and it's going to put a lot of pressure
here so a3 by white uh and
now rook a to b8 now the rooks have
shifted from a and b to b
and c and rajabo has some different
plans and here
queen to b2 freeing up the c3 square for
the rook
but there was the very interesting e6
it's a bit a bit of a forcing line
uh but i will show it um probably both
of them checked it and decided
obviously decided that it's not worth
going for the idea is after the
pawn is accepted then you go bishop to
f4 you threaten the rook here and now
it's good if the rook moves if the rook
moves then you're just going to play
rook captures on e6 and you have a
beautiful attack f captures and now
queen to e3
is just a a very very very powerful
position you have a lot of holes here
and the white will have
a fun time playing this position the
knight can come to if
f3 then to g5 or e5 it's just going to
be
very very hard for black to defend this
problem is after bishop to f4 you don't
have to
move the rook to b7 you can just ignore
that and play bishop to g7 now going
after this
and now it's we just trade everything
off bishop captures on g8 bishop
captures on d4 attacking the queen and
the f2 pawn
so the queen defends that queen g3 and
now we get queen captures on b8 offer a
queen trade and after this trade
captures captures uh you get rook
captures on c6
bishop to b2 going after the a3 pawn a4
and now
black would start pushing his d pawn and
wesley would be up the exchange but
black would have the bishop pair and the
the past
d-pawn so it's very very unclear and
wesley doesn't uh doesn't want to go
into this forcing line
unless he's sure it's winning so instead
he plays a queen to b2 he now wants to
further improve the position
uh with rook to c3 and so on maybe bring
the other rook to c1
uh we have queen to d8 uh and uh now
rook to c3 and now queen to d7 with this
queen to the e8 to d7 maneuver uh
rajabov says that he definitely has some
plans of maybe
maybe even attacking the king side which
was not
the case uh so far so rook e to c1
wesley ignores this
just continues his play on the queen
side here and now f6
busting or trying to bust open the
center we have
rook to c5 wesley again ignores this he
goes after the a5 pawn he wants to grab
that and have a
have a beautiful past a pawn and now
rook to b5 defending
uh but of course wesley doesn't trade he
forces arajava to trade
on c5 so he does rook captures rook
captures again
going after the a5 pawn and now it's a
question what do you do here
best for black is to just trade in the
center captures captures queen c7
defend the pawn and enjoy this kind of a
passive position but
maybe uh you know maybe it's the best
black has but uh
tamer not a very passive player himself
he decides to go for the active bishop
captures on h3
and now what's happening here you have
to capture the bishop otherwise you've
just lost a pawn
and that's that's no fun so g captures
an h3
queen captures an h3 and now knight to
f1
and this is the uh the the really
the really cool move because if wesley
doesn't find the knight to f1
then uh then tamor really has a
beautiful attack quinji for check the h
pawn starts marching uh down the board
and knight to f1
is not an easy move to find and uh i'll
tell you why
for example f captures on e4 f captures
an e5 was played in the game
d captures and now bishop to g7 freeing
up
this f8 square for the rook but now uh
the thing is instead of this you could
have gone for queen to g for check and i
know you guys are wondering but
why not to do this uh the problem is
after knights to g3 and h4
that wesley has this beautiful defensive
resource of queen to e2
and now the black queen is hanging and
of course if you trade then white is
very happy white is up a p
up a piece and in a completely winning
end game and if you don't uh you can
play something else you can move the
queen let's say queen to b4
but it's not a problem just knight to f1
you move the knight
and uh you do not want to capture the g3
pawn
because then you lose control of the g4
square and from g4
uh white will be attacking the g6 pawn
and the rook as well
and it's now completely winning for
white so you have to play something like
e6 but then rogue goes back to c1 and
again it's a
much much better position for white so
maybe this is something
uh the job of overlooked when uh
planning this sacrifice that uh
that wesley will in fact be able to
defend with knight to g3
because if not for that uh rajabo's
attack would just go through
queen g4 followed by pushing the h pawn
would be sufficient
so here bishop to g7 rajabo now has to
bring another piece into the game rook
to f8 is coming
and now queen to d4 so just uh
centralizing the queen
preparing to shift the queen over to the
to the king side and now queen back to
e6 with a double attack on this pawn but
wesley says
not a problem i'm just going to capture
on a5 create a pass pawn and i'm going
to start pushing it
so bishop captures on e5 and now queen
to h4 the bishop and queen nicely stop
all of thamer's kingside pawns so
rook to f8 he brings the rook into the
game but now rook to a7 threatening to
pick up the
the a7 pawn here as the queen also
attacks it so here you have to decide
between bishop to f6
uh but then bishop to g5 is again uh
go kind of goes in wesley's favor as he
gets the tray down
uh even further so uh tamar decides to
keep the material on the board he plays
bishop to d6
and now b4 are continuing to push those
pawns queen is defending the b four pawn
so it's not a problem
uh we have rook to f3 and now
rook to a8 with check even if uh
even a rook a check is the best move but
even if wesley plays something weird
let's say he plays a5 there's still no
way to attack here
for example rook h3 attacks the queen
queen g5 and queen e4 now threatening
checkmate
uh it's uh not enough just going to g2
defends everything offers a queen trade
attacks the rook so
white is perfectly fine here but wesley
did go for the absolute best
rook to a8 with check uh king to f7 and
now of course
bishop to h6 going after that uh rook to
f8 we've reached the position from the
thumbnail
and now wesley is threatening checkmate
the only way
to avoid checkmate is to move the queen
so the king has a square to escape so
here
queen to e2 uh but now rook to f8 all
the same this comes with
check king to e6 and now comes a rook
trade so
rook captures and queen captures uh
wesley has to trade down as
as for as you know as far as possible uh
because
the more he trades down the more he's
going to enjoy his extra uh
extra piece and he's just going to push
his pass pawn to victory
so here bishop back to e3 uh and
now comes king to d7 now rajabo has to
bring the
king all the way to the queen side to
stop help those those past pawns so a5
king to c8 and now comes bishop to c5
offering a trade of yet another piece
and here you have to
you have to check is queen to f4 maybe
possible for black because it does look
appealing because if queen captures
bishop captures and let's say bishop
captures on e7
maybe you can start pushing your d pawn
uh problem is you can't
after bishop c5 d3 it seems like you're
very close but bishop to e3 stops the
bishops uh defense of the d2 square the
knight defense that you
you offer a trade and now white is
completely winning here
but you have to check so bishop the f4
instead just moving the bishop and then
now comes queen captures on e7 so now
wesley
grabs even more material queen to g for
check
knights the g3 now asking are you maybe
interested in pushing that h pawn
uh but not really because if if you do
go for this then you get queen to
e8 with check and now uh now there are
all sorts of problems for example if
king to c7
bishop to b6 with check king to b7
and now you get to this beautiful queen
to e7 with
check uh the king has to move it doesn't
really matter where you move the king of
king here you can play b5 with
check and the the position is just
beautiful
uh if you capture with the pawn we can
even show this then queen to a7 is
checkmate so that doesn't work
so you would have to go further in with
the king king here but then queen to c5
with
check and again what do you play here um
if you go
if you go here uh it doesn't really
matter king here queen captures and then
you have all sorts of nasty discoveries
with the bishop
and if you go down the board king to a4
then queen captures on c6 with
check and you're just gonna push this
king all the way down king the king to
b3 or a3 doesn't really matter you're
gonna capture here with check king to be
for queen d4 with
check and now you've already won uh so
much material that you don't really care
king to b3 queen to d3 with check you
can play king back to b4
then a6 is coming and once this is
finally captures
h captures here uh you don't really care
you just push a7 and
there's nothing and nothing to be done
here if g captures on f2 you can just
play king captures
and all of the defenders are already
here so it's not a problem it looks very
scary
but of course both of them are
incredibly strong and they know that
you're not going to be able to do
anything here once the king finds a
safe square then the the the past eight
pawn is just winning
so uh uh scary stuff but uh of course
agrees that this is no way to go so he
tries bishop captures on g3
he will try to go for some sort of a
perpetual here
f captures and now queen captures on g3
with
check king to f1 queen to d3 with
check king f2 now queen d2 with check
king of three queen d1 check king of
four and now queen to g4
with check uh we have king to e5 and now
queen to e4 with check king goes to f6
and now there's a problem
if you deliver one more check after king
g7 there are no more checks this is
covered by the bishop this is covered by
the queen
so you would have to just uh surrender
here so after king to f6 we have queen
captures on e7
he tries to go for this end game but
it's going to be very hard king captures
and now
h4 he starts pushing his pass pawn king
to d6 now
we have h3 and now bishop to g2 just
stopping that pass pawn but now comes d4
and of course you cannot capture the
pawn because then you allow this pawn to
become a queen
so here wesley just captures on c6 but
now
d3 and now it's a question can these two
pawns uh
uh you know uh tackle the bishop but a6
here
with a king to b8 uh if you push d2 here
then it's not a problem just a7 you
bring a queen into the game and the
white brings a queen into the game with
checkmate because the king prevents the
black king from
going anywhere so here after a6 king to
b8
this is a must but it's not a problem b5
we have d2 and now now comes a7
with check this is beautiful stuff the
bishop covers the a7 pawn so king the a8
and now comes b6 and it was in this
position that
uh team rajabo resigned the game as
whatever you do your check made it on
the next move so any move black plays
let's say you bring a queen into the
game
b7 is checkmate because the king has
nowhere to go this is covered this
covered this check and that's just it
so really really amazing game for a
rapid game it's
super crazy because it's an extremely
complicated game and
it's really awesome that they were able
to to pull off such a game with so many
possibilities uh in
in rapid format but wesley never
hindered for a second
he he did not uh you know lose uh what's
happening uh you know in the position
uh even for one move and after uh
taymur sacrificed that bishop on h3
wesley was just constantly better and he
gave uh
uh no chance whatsoever so uh rajab
tried to play
very very actively he didn't want to
play that passive position on the queen
side that we've shown he sacrificed
bishop for two pawns which is usually
great in itself but here wesley just
played a
perfect rapid game from that moment on
and uh well
wesley won game three in game four uh uh
taymor had the the white pieces again
but that game ended in a draw
so match one goes to wesley and the
tamer will have an opportunity today to
bounce back and maybe force tie breaks
so we'll see we'll see what happens uh
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it i
i enjoyed it immensely if i do say so
myself uh i would like to thank
pratamish mahajan no deathman luis
burkhart
david kimura and harry lewin for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing the coverage
of the opera euro rapid checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank y'all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day